[Musique]
il était une fois un lieu à poissy où le
monde de l'enfance est à l'honneur trois
niveaux sont entièrement consacrées aux
jeux et aux jouets à travers les
différentes époques
il y à 43 ans ce musée du jouet est le
premier du genre à être créés en france
l'idée est venue du conservateur du
musée pédagogique qui était de l'huma
paris qui était en fait l'héritier du du
musée de jules ferry du musée de l'école
et c'est cette conservatrice
quesnoysiens 70 dans ce musée
pédagogique avait toute une collection
de jouets et elle a cherché un lieu qui
pouvait accueillir cette collection de
jouets pour qu'il soit mieux valoriser
donc nous sommes à peu les héritiers du
musée de jules ferry d' les années 1880
depuis son ouverture en 1976 c'est la
deuxième fois que le musée fermé au
public pour des travaux de rénovation
il faut dire que le bâtiment qui abrite
ses collections de jouets est inscrit au
titre des monuments historiques
nous nous trouvons ici dans la porterie
du prieuré royal saint louis de poissy
qui a été construit au tout début du 14e
siècle par philippe le bel en l'honneur
de son grand-père saint louis qui est né
et a été baptisé ici apprécie
[Musique]
restauration des façades mise aux normes
accessibilité ou encore création d'une
extension
le chantier a duré trois ans objectif
que le public soit accueilli dans de
meilleures conditions et ainsi mieux
voyager dans ses souvenirs d'enfance les
collections présentées ont été en grande
partie renouvelé il ya eu un grand
chantier de restauration des collections
de dépoussiérage et là on présente à peu
près 600 objets sur 14000 qui sont
conservés dans les collections
ils sont en grande partie le fruit de
dons de dons de particuliers de
collection c'est que nous ont été légués
et sinon c'est des achats les achats
faits en salle des ventes des achats
faits auprès de particuliers auprès
d'antiquaires le parcours muséographique
a été repensée avec une approche
chronologique du jouet une visite
également plus ludique à travers cette
vitrine on peut par exemple découvrir
cette poupée parlante du second empire
plus insolite encore cette collection de
jouets remontant à l'antiquité prêtés
par le musée du louvre
nous avons déjà là des poupées nous
avons une toupie des osselets le tout
étant introduit par un panneau de
sarcophage sans doute d'une sépulture
d'enfants donc c'est un un dépôt
d'objets magnifiques d'une grande
ancienneté
un voyage dans le temps possible dès le
11 mai pour ainsi retrouver son âme
d'enfant
[Musique]